j'accueille jean-marie vigueur
jean maheux garden choix
jean- marié le magazine le magazine
capital vous annonce comme l'humoriste
que plus rentable de france
absolument on dit que vous gagnez 5,4
millions d'euros par an moi je sais même
pas comment ça fait c d euros le
deuxième cgra avec 3 47 millions d'euros
ensuite il ya jamel debbouze avec 3
millions d'euros c'est beaucoup d'argent
un mois ils sont gourés c'est beaucoup
plus mais en fait comme j'étais en tête
ça m'a pas gêné parce que le pire c'est
d'être troisième ou deuxième ou
quatrième vague était promis à ses
quatre adjoints
c'est fait depuis je reçois beaucoup
plus de courrier ouais les infos sur
tout le haut ça va est ce que j'ai
trouvé un truc imparable je les paye
j'ai toujours désiré tranquille c'est
bien dans sa planque courrier et jean
capelle qui disent ce que du problème
des pannes et 200000 euros je suis
intérêts de 80000 mais deux mois sans
comme ça se fera un peu d'avant je sais
que je ne sais rien mais moi ça me
dépanne révèle alors en tous les cas
jean marie tout cet argent ne vous
empêche pas de vous soucier du du sort
des autres je ne fais que ça c'est
d'ailleurs étonnant qu'il m'en reste
autant bah oui et aujourd'hui vous
sortez un dvd qui regroupe 30 sketches
des meilleurs humoristes francophones
tranquille aux communes
voilà sur la même galette ouais c'est du
jamais vu ok ouais c'est un dvd c'est à
dire c'est du son et de l'image jamais
certainement que ça ne se reproduira
plus jamais ça lui met d'accord tout un
tas de débuter un tsunami
paris
m
parce que voilà non c'est vrai il a
fallu que le film nanny pour 1 regroupe
les trente deux comiques sur le même dvd
c'est extraordinaire oui et d'abord ça
s'est jamais fait parce que nous et un
je salue
1 2 3 4 nez dessus déjà tu es toi oui
aujourd'hui et il m'a appelé tout de
suite parce que il est un droit
laurent n'ose lui dire ses 16 ça s'est
jamais fait les chanteurs on fait
souvent des tas de compile jamais eu
trente deux comiques en dvd sur le sur
la même galette et donc c'est imparable
que j'ai envie de dire que même celui
qui a envie de rien donner du tout est
oublié d'acheter si c'était une page de
garde date où les noms qui sont lot un
curseur tu cliques tu veux laurent
ruquier 4 et c'est génial parce que moi
je les regardais et j'ai découvert plein
de trucs que tu peux pas les voir toutes
époques les 32 vraiment oui y'en a ils
sont les moins connais toi c'est guy
bedos muriel robin antoine de caunes les
deschiens franck dubosc gad elmaleh
ricard allons-y de trois balles des
pierres palmade toi jean marie lycées
vous mais ça ce serait dire qu'il n'ya
pas finalement
ouais non ce que je veux dire c'est que
j'associe tous les autres parce que pour
tout un tas de raisons n'a été vachement
pressé par le temps j'ai ceci toute la
famille des des comics ont fait une
espèce de petite démonstration de
solidarité qui est s'était jamais fait
et qui n'est pas prêt de se reproduire
et franchement à ce prix là c'est bon
quand on sait que disons on voit la
croix rouge
et si on nous vend 1 million je reviens
ici et je me rase les poils pubiens
devant tout le monde
au milieu est il sorti aujourd'hui
peut-être déjà vendu à améliorer je
confirme
un rôle de sa commune reste très très
peu de moustache avec deux ans à part 2
oui
c'est à dieu ça dure trois heures en
plus 3h03 jamais et surtout si tu dis tu
te sers vraiment à la carte que si tu
veux choisir tous sur la même page de
plus simple du monde
et puis très attrayant tu dis tiens je
vais me faire clac clac clac du t5 covic
tout est évidemment ce sont des morceaux
choisis et 10 sièges que j'ai découvert
- carrément de copains qui faisait des
trucs que je connaissais pas alors là on
va faire un truc on va regarder non pas
à quoi ça ressemble ce serait trop long
on va regarder le petit film de
publicité way qui a été fait et là je
vous repose un truc qu'on n'a jamais
fait pire que tout le monde ont régi sur
le plateau tout le monde a créé en même
temps quand je vais dire toc magnéto
serge attention à 2,3